and there is there's really not much
mystery to it in many ways because if
there was a mystery to it they wouldn't
be effective at broadcasting but what
you really want to do when you're
looking for those sorts of things is
look in spaces which you can
unambiguously associate with the person
when people usually help you out in this
way so you see you see a poster of some
sort of icon that's important to them on
their desk or on that on their door or
something like that there may be other
things to which have more personal
meaning which you can't really interpret
so you know you have a pebble from the
beach where you had your first kiss or
something like that you know and you
might see that pebble and not really
know what it means but you would notice
oscillation dimension